[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi and welcome
to episode number 130
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel.
And I'm here with my colleague,
as always, Melanie Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Doing good, Mark.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
very, very well.
Yet another week,
yet another podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Another podcast--
130.
MARK MANDEL: 130,
it's a good number.
MELANIE WARRICK: Another
20 and we'll be at 150.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Math is good.
MELANIE WARRICK: Math is good.
[LAUGHTER]
I can do math.
MARK MANDEL: You can do math.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark,
so this week we have
two wonderful women who
have joined us to talk
about data science pipelines
and tools.
So Juliet and Michelle
are both with us.
And Juliet is actually
the data platform
lead over at Stitch Fix.
And Michelle is one
of our colleagues
who works with us here at Google
and does a lot of great things
around machine learning
and Google Cloud Platform.
So before we get
into that, as always,
we are going to talk about
cool things of the week.
And our question of the week
is that if I have written
a gRPC service but I'm using
a language platform that
isn't supported, is there any
way I can access it as rest?
I wonder where this
question came from.
MARK MANDEL: I don't
know, maybe me.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Maybe someone who
is hacking on it this weekend.
Anyway, so we'll get to
that question in a minute
but before that, some of
the cool things of the week.
I'm going to start with the
fact that Sandeep Dinesh, who
is one of our
colleagues on the team,
he's been doing this
great video series
that's video logs, video
blogs, video something.
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sure.
So he's been doing the series
under the name of "Kubernetes
Best Practices."
And he recently published
the last episode
in his seven-part series.
And so we will include
that in show notes.
And the last episode is
"Upgrading your Cluster
was Zero Downtime."
So if you've got a cluster,
how do you get that updated?
And you don't have to
really spend any effort.
MARK MANDEL: And there's
a great photo of him
in the video pointing
at the camera.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's right.
MARK MANDEL: It's
just a great photo.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's a good job.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Now, and
he's got-- all of the videos
that he's done on the
subject are really wonderful.
So if you haven't seen
it and you have questions
about Kubernetes and
work with containers,
you should watch them.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
they're really good.
Want to send a shout
out and congratulations
to the Helm project.
helm is a package manage
solution for Kubernetes.
They recently have been voted
to be accepted into the Cloud
Native Compute Foundation as
an incubation level hosted
project.
So congratulations, CNF.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yay!
MARK MANDEL: And congratulations
to Helm, I should say.
MELANIE WARRICK: Golf clap?
Golf clap.
MARK MANDEL: And
CNCF, both of them.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So the other thing
we were going to
mention for this week is
that Android P is in beta.
This is the next
release of Android.
And they've got some
great new features
that are going on that have to
do with adaptive efficiencies
within the Android
operating system in general,
like prioritizing battery
power for the apps
that you're using the most
or in terms of the brightness
and trying to adapt the
brightness of your device
so it's more efficient and
works longer, works better.
Some of the cool things
that they mention
are things like
app actions, trying
to determine what actual actions
you're taking with the app
and bringing up adaptively
what you might want based
on your previous, I don't
know, whatever you just opened
or whatever you just
were looking at.
MARK MANDEL: Before I go to bed,
for example, I set my alarm.
So I'm guessing it's
going to show me my alarm.
MELANIE WARRICK: So it'll
bring up your alarm quickly.
Or something they said was like
if you connect your headphones
to the device and you
typically bring up Spotify,
that it will more quickly
identify your Spotify
playlist for you, stuff like
that, which I think is great--
anything that makes it
go faster and easier.
Anyway, so that's
available in beta.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
And somewhat self-servingly, the
Agones project that I work on
is going to have a 0.2 release.
It should be out today.
The release candidates
out already.
But literally, I think, as this
thing gets released either very
shortly after or very quickly
before, one [INAUDIBLE],,
0.2 should be out so they
will have, speaking of Helm,
actually, Helm packaging,
which is lovely also--
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: --and
fleet management.
And we're also moving to a
six-week release cycle as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: And one day we
will do a podcast about Agones.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I know.
You've been bugging me about it.
We have some plans.
We're going to do it.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We've got some plans.
MARK MANDEL: I have some plans.
MELANIE WARRICK: One day.
One day.
Last thing we're
going to mention,
and we'll include
the show notes,
is there is a nice blog
post out about securing
cloud-connected devices with
Cloud IoT and micro-chip.
And this goes a little bit
to this idea of the YubiKeys,
but it's a microchip
that you can
use in helping you
to, in essence,
secure the devices without
taking too much memory
and without having to do any
remote uploads or downloads.
It's a better way to secure your
IoTs from the various hacking
that can happen.
MARK MANDEL: Fancy.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
So, yeah, great
details in the article.
We'll include it.
And you can check it out.
Mark--
MARK MANDEL: Shall we go
talk to Juliet and Michelle?
MELANIE WARRICK:
I think we should.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
This week's podcast, we
are excited to have with us
two wonderful science experts.
We have Michelle Casbon,
who's one of our colleagues,
and we have Juliet Hoagland,
who is from Stitch Fix.
And thank you both for
coming on the podcast.
MICHELE CASBON: It's
great to be here.
Thanks for having us.
JULIET HOUGLAND: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
Michelle can you start off
by telling us a little
bit about yourself
and what you do at Google?
MICHELE CASBON: Sure.
I'm fairly new to the team.
I joined the GCP DevRel
team as an engineer.
And I split my time between
advocating for the open source
community of Kubeflow--
that's the machine learning
on Kubernetes-- as
well as Dataproc,
which is our managed YARN
service, managed Spark on YARN
here.
So my role is really
to operate in the space
between internal developers
and external developers
and try to make the
experience better for people
using our tools externally
and also bringing
that feedback to our
internal product teams
and making those better.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
And Juliet, I know you're
the data platform engineering
manager over at Stitch Fix.
Can you tell us a little
bit about what you're doing
and your background?
JULIET HOUGLAND: Sure.
So I'm a data platform
engineering manager
at Stitch Fix.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Ah, you're one of--
JULIET HOUGLAND: Yes.
The team that I manage
does workflow environment
and execution.
So what does it mean to run
a job on our infrastructure?
What does it mean to
schedule it, run it reliably,
build images that you're going
to be running these things in?
A lot of that
infrastructure exists.
But what we're
working towards now
is having a more unified,
easy-to-use interface for it
and having it hang together.
And so my background is
a mixture of data science
and engineering.
Since grad school,
I've sort of switched
between heavy engineering
and heavy data science jobs.
And I like being somewhere
in that interface
and building good tools
for data scientists.
So I'm pretty excited to
be working at Stitch Fix,
building good tools for
our data scientists.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Yes.
And I know today we wanted to
get into data science, what
it is, what it means, as well as
talk about some of the tooling
around that and
what you're using.
So to kick us off, how do
you define data science?
JULIET HOUGLAND: Sure.
So Stitch Fix has
a department called
algorithms and analytics.
And the algorithms and
analytics department
is vertically oriented.
Meaning we work with styling.
We work with clients.
We work with merchandising
and operations,
like our warehouse operations.
And the data scientists on our
team do a variety of things
but try to enable and
optimize the business
through using data well.
And we err on the side of trying
to do that problematically
and automatically as opposed
to having one of our business
partners come to
a data scientist
and say, hey, like,
I have this question.
Build me a report.
So a lot of what our
data scientists do
is try to build systems and
levers into the business that
help the business run more
efficiently and optimize it.
So a great example is warehouse
routing and optimization
of how do people that
are picking items
of like [INAUDIBLE]
clothing and off of racks
walk through the warehouse to
minimize the distance, right?
So that's not a definition,
but that's how we practice it.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
And I've seen
different companies
have different definitions
for what that means for them.
So Michelle, how do you
define data science?
MICHELE CASBON: Yeah.
Actually this is one of
the most loaded questions
that I ever get.
Like Juliet, so my back on has
also been heavy engineering.
Started out with
computer science degrees
and kind of gone back and
forth between data science,
like official data science roles
and official engineering rules.
And there's been a lot of
variability in those roles
but the same person and
mostly the same skill
set for all the
different titles and all
the different responsibilities.
So I feel like,
exactly as you said,
every company has their
own definition of it.
And it's kind of
grown organically.
It's still like a
fairly young field
and going through especially
data science interviews are
one of the most confusing
things to prepare for because
of those differing definitions
and the different expectations.
I feel like it's
definitely blending more
into there's less of a
differentiation between data
engineering and data science.
Mostly I feel like it's
just an umbrella term.
And it's a way for
people to describe hey,
there's this magical thing
that I want to happen,
and I need people
with math skills,
with engineering
skills, people who
can actually build something
to solve a particular problem.
But there's a lot of
contention in this area,
and specifically I
feel like it kind
of fuels the fire of data
science versus engineering
that I think is kind
of counterproductive.
So I'm going to decline from
giving a specific definition.
JULIET HOUGLAND: Yeah.
And I think even within
what you're describing,
I've heard data
science decomposed
into three areas
of data science,
where you have
inference and A/B test,
you have decision
science, like how
do you come to some sort
of business conclusion
or decide what a
business should do,
and then you also have the
sort of machine learning
engineering
building-automatic-systems type
of data science.
And so I think those are
three categories of what
data scientists do that
require different skill sets
and experience.
And you can get
deep in any of them.
And what you're describing
with engineering,
I think all of them
benefit from engineering.
But some have better tooling
already and some don't.
Decision science and
inference, I think,
have relatively good
tooling in existence.
Whereas the machinery
and engineering,
the tooling is kind
of lacking and new.
MICHELE CASBON:
Yeah, that's true.
And it requires a
lot more engineering
in order to enable that area.
JULIET HOUGLAND:
Yeah, definitely.
MARK MANDEL: You
mentioned there's tooling.
What sort of tooling does
exist for those areas
that you're
particularly fond of?
MICHELE CASBON: I mean it's
getting better over the years,
but it's been pretty lacking.
I guess traditionally the
decision science tools,
things like SaaS, Matlab, things
that are more heavy on the math
side, but actually putting
those into production systems,
we've kind of seen a shift
from traditional software
engineering tools that have been
sort of adapted over the years
to things that are more
specific to do science.
I guess in the past I've
seen things like Informatica,
just data fork lifting tools,
back-end systems like Teradata
to try and solve the distributed
compute problem, up to today.
The biggest shift I
have seen in the space
is with Kubernetes
and being able to take
a lot of those very
specific problems
and run them in a
single environment.
That's where I've
seen a big shift
from these sort of very
specific science tools
solving one specific problem
into a more general purpose
fitting more into that
traditional software
development role, where you
have all these pieces that
can interact together
in a repeatable way.
And you can deploy it,
and you can be confident
that that code hasn't
changed and that things
haven't changed in between.
And you can be a lot
more robust and sort of
adopt those traditional
software development practices
into more of the data science,
machine learning space.
JULIET HOUGLAND: Yeah.
I've seen-- I think there's
a ton of different tools
out there at different levels
of the data stack, right?
There's a ton of new
data processing libraries
that run on people's machines.
So scikit-learn has been
around for a while, but a ton--
like xgboost is getting a
huge amount of traction,
things like PyTorch
and TensorFlow,
huge amount of traction.
Those are booming.
And they often require
specialized hardware.
But that brings up
the question of,
once you have these
programs running
and a data scientist has
built some sort of model
that works on their laptop,
that's not production.
We need to be able to actually
use the infrastructure that we
have and put these things
on some sort of schedule
and know where these are
going to get executed
and in what environment.
And so there's a huge
amount of tooling around
how do you take something
that works on someone's laptop
and make it robust,
reliable, scheduled?
And I think things
like Kubernetes--
or at Stitch Fix
we have a system
called Flotilla, which is
used for defining a job
and what that job
might look like.
And so a job has a Docker image.
It has a run command.
It has environment
variables, things like that.
And beyond this job definition,
you also want scheduling.
And once you have
scheduling, you
have to begin to think about,
well, this is not one person
scheduling something.
This is actually
a variety of teams
that have a variety of needs.
And they're all
sharing a resource.
And you begin to
pretty quickly get
into queues and
scheduling and what
it means for having
some sort of fair share
between different teams on
cluster resources that we have.
And so the things that have
been solved on supercomputers,
then solving for
resource managers,
you end up beginning to
think about your own systems.
So I think there's lots of
different places in the stack
where new tools exist.
Some of these can be a data
access, data processing tools.
SQL has been around forever,
at least in computer years.
And beyond that, there's tons
of larger scale data processing
tools.
At Stitch Fix we don't
frequently have to use them.
We do have a Spark
cluster and we use it
for a variety of things.
But it's pretty rare
for our data scientists
to build models that
are distributed.
But we do have, if you count
all of our data together,
a large amount of data
that people are moving
kind of all over the place.
There's a lot of different
tools that interlock.
But I would say there's data
access, client libraries,
and then cluster resource
scheduling kind of tools
that people can actually use
it in our cloud infrastructure.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
know, Juliet, you
were talking about how do
science is seen at Stitch Fix.
Would you also say that
your data from engineering,
is that seen as more
like data engineering?
Is that also classified under
the data science umbrella?
How do you guys partner?
JULIET HOUGLAND: The way that
data science and data platform
interact at Stitch
fix is that we
expect data scientists to own
their workflows end to end.
And this is pretty unique
because a lot of companies
have data engineers that
hook up the pipes to make
sure the data's getting
to the right place
in the right formats
so data scientists can
do their modeling.
And we think that
there's something
that you trade in
a system like that.
What you're trading is the
data will get there reliably
in whatever format
it gets there.
But then there's this
interaction and handoff
where a data scientists
will model something,
and they realize that the
pipeline needs to be changed.
And so they go back to
the data engineer and say,
hey, you need to
go fix this thing.
You need to change the format.
And we don't want
head off like that.
A lot of statistics
data science is--
Stitch Fix algorithms
in general is really
focused on autonomy
and ownership
and we design the organization
for quick iteration on models.
And that means not having
handoff between data platform
and data science.
And so the reason that
we're on the data platform
and we're not data
engineers is that we
build tools to allow data
scientists to be self-service
and to be independent in
owning their workflows.
And so that's a pretty different
model than a lot of companies,
and it's one of
the reasons I think
it's pretty interesting to
work there building tools.
MICHELE CASBON: Yeah.
I feel like that approach
is really pioneering.
I didn't really know a
whole lot about that,
but sort of independently
arrived at something
very similar at the previous
company that I worked for.
That sort of enablement
and empowering
all of your engineers
and data scientists
to be able to deploy their
own stuff from conception,
from the very beginning, all
the way through to production
and then to iterate on that,
that saves so much time
and not having that handoff, not
having that human interaction,
and having ask for permission
and being added to a pipeline
or queue, like, managing that
human resource side of things,
I felt like that was
very transformative
and just being able to iterate
on models so much more quickly
and not having
them get stale, not
having them be sort of out
of date already by the time
they make it to production.
That ownership and that
empowerment is really critical.
I feel like you guys
have such a huge custom,
sort of, hand-built
architecture.
You have your own
system that manages
all that, that supports that.
But I also think
that it's something,
like for me, Kubernetes
really enabled that.
And it's also something that
you don't need an entire team
to do for you.
Like, I feel like the
tools are there in order
to enable that process.
And you don't have to be like
a sophisticated data science
institution in order to do that.
MELANIE WARRICK: What do you
think are some of the bigger
challenges in this space?
JULIET HOUGLAND: I think in
our particular situation,
the self-service model, it
is good in a variety of ways,
but there are obvious drawbacks
and sort of trade-offs, right?
When experienced data
engineers are the ones building
the pipelines, then you're going
to have more robust pipelines.
And so trying to
figure out systems
and tooling to make it easier
to build robust pipelines,
in our case, is definitely
a big challenge.
How do we allow scientists
to be self-service and still
sort of push them in
the direction of highest
quality possible and highest
reliability possible?
And that's a problem
that's specific to us.
But when I think about problems
in general that a lot of people
are facing and thinking about,
scheduling, complex workflows,
and versioning
complex workflows,
I think having
reproducibility of models
is very related to being able to
understand where data came from
and where model artifacts
or dashboards came from
and what definitions
are being used.
And this is a pretty
common problem
that ends up being talked
about in the hallway
track of conferences, right?
People at data
engineering conferences
will begin to discuss
issues that they have.
And often it'll will
be, oh, this open source
project is always falling over.
Or what is this data, and
where did it come from?
And how do you go about
providing that visibility
to users?
MICHELE CASBON: Yeah.
I feel like the larger story
is the sort of dirty secret
of data science just
because people really
want to talk about the
algorithms themselves
and what cool techniques
they're using.
But I feel like the bigger
problem, and the place where
people spend more time,
is just on the system
as a whole and not that one
machine learning component.
I feel like that's a
much smaller piece.
And stitching all
those pieces together
is a non-trivial problem
for reproducibility sake,
for interpretability
sake, for being
able to actually trace back,
here's a result that we got.
But where did it come from
and how did we arrive on that?
There are a lot of reasons why
you might want to know that.
The other challenge
I see is just
getting things from that
sort of experimental phase
into production without
having a whole lot of things
change in between, so being able
to like work locally and then
transform that into
something running on a dev
cluster and then into production
and being able to make sure
that it's the same
model that was intended
by the first person
who first built it.
And that whole
empowerment and being
able to deploy your own
models, I feel like,
really helps to solve that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And is that where
tools like using something
like Kubernetes, Kubeflow
to be able to help
with reproducibility,
as well as moving it
from local to global
would potentially come in?
MICHELE CASBON: Exactly.
Yeah, that's a big
idea behind Kubeflow.
It supports the whole machine
learning application, so
as a single unit
instead of trying
to deploy lots of
different pieces
and lots of different places.
The idea behind
it is essentially
to take that entire
application, so not just the ML,
but the logging, the
monitoring, the front end, all
of the auditing, all of
the versioning, everything
packaging up into one place and
being able to run that locally
for yourself, being
able to access that
through a JupyterHub.
So having other people access it
in a single component cluster,
but then being able to
take that exact same code,
change a couple
environment commands,
and run it in the cloud,
in a different cloud,
on a completely different set of
physical hardware, or on prem,
or any combination of that.
It's meant to
solve that problem.
JULIET HOUGLAND: So
I think that gets
at a large part of the
reproducibility problem
of the environment and the
code that you're running.
But one of the
biggest challenges
that I've seen in any type
of statistical learned model
is the data part.
The thing that makes these
sort of systems challenging
for reproducibility is the
tight coupling between the data
that you're using,
like what data did
you use to build this model?
Or what data is it
expecting in, and what kind
of statistical
distribution is it
good at producing
predictions for?
| a tight coupling there.
And I think that systems that
help with the environment
and help with the
software piece of it
but trying to understand the
connection to that data that
is actually being used
is a big, big challenge.
And it's not something
that is solved in a way
that the industry in general
can point to and be like,
ah, yes, this is the
industry best practice.
This is something that everyone
talks about and doesn't
have a good solution to,
as far as I've heard.
MICHELE CASBON:
Yeah, so I've seen
a couple of tools come
up pretty recently that I
haven't tried out.
Kubeflow supports
one of them one.
One I think is Pachyderm.
And then another is Quilt Data.
And both of them--
I've looked into them but
just haven't used them
in a production capacity.
And they're trying to
solve that exact problem.
JULIET HOUGLAND: I've
only looked at Pachyderm.
And I really like
the idea behind it.
But its version of data
versioning is very heavyweight.
From what I saw,
what you do is you
bring your data
into a container,
and then you version it there.
And so basically
Pachyderm works, but only
if everything is inside
this universe of Pachyderm.
MICHELE CASBON: Mm, I see.
JULIET HOUGLAND: And I see that
as very heavyweight and not
something that people
can easily adopt
in systems that exist already.
MICHELE CASBON: Interesting.
JULIET HOUGLAND: And perhaps if
you're building something new,
like brand new, or you're
willing to make that sacrifice
and move it entirely
into that type of system,
I see it as heavyweight.
But I haven't dug deeper
into actually using it.
MICHELE CASBON: Yeah,
I'd be interested to hear
how Stitch Fix solves that
problem in the future.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, and I actually
was going to ask
that in terms of I
know you don't know exactly
what the best practices are.
This is something people
are trying to go after.
What are some best
practices or ways
that you guys are
trying to approach
these types of problems
for reproducibility
that you think would be good to
see others attempt, or at least
is useful for your group?
JULIET HOUGLAND: So
we're thinking about it
in terms of decomposing
the problem first into data
versioning and then
artifact versioning.
So what is this data,
and how did it get here?
What is this process
that generated
and the sense of being very
deeply linked to data lineage.
And so data lineage, I
think of as this table
and this partition
was the input.
Here is a process
or a job that is
the thing that used that input.
And you maybe have a
collection of inputs, right?
And then the output
is a table, columns,
partitions that this
thing gets written to.
And so you have
some sort of-- you
need some sort of meta
information that says,
this is the link
between these tables.
And this is the version
of the job that ran.
So you version the job,
and you version the data.
And so that's one way that
we're beginning to look at this.
That was actually a project
I was working on before I
started managing this team.
And I decided to put
it on the back burner
until this team is--
I feel more comfortable
in my role basically.
MELANIE WARRICK: Understandable.
JULIET HOUGLAND: But
once that is in place,
I think you need good
data versioning before you
get model versioning.
And model versioning, I
think, is a holy grail
that many companies
would like to have.
You would think many companies
could say that like, oh yes,
I know what this model is.
I know what went into it.
And I think you would be
wrong in almost all of them.
I've definitely heard rumors
of certain types of models
that you would think would be
very resilient and robust not
being reproducible and having
no way of recreating them
if a disk drive were
to fail, for example.
I'm sure they're
replicating them.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We actually have
the team, the folks who are
working in Project Jupyter
here a few weeks back.
And we talked about
reproducibility
is one of the goals
for some of the things
that they're building out
as well, that they know
that that's a clear problem
that's going on in general
but that the effort to
try to solve for that.
JULIET HOUGLAND: Well,
I think this ends up
being really related to why
do people do data science?
I'd say some people do data
science to say that they are,
right?
There are some companies
that are like, ooh, yeah,
this is our AI strategy, right?
And some people do data
science because they want
to deliver value to a business.
And if what you're trying to do
is deliver value to a business,
you need to have credibility.
You need to be able to
clearly explain yourself
to business partners and have
them believe that what you've
made is useful.
And for that you might not
need the holy grail version
of model visibility and
versioning and reproducibility.
But you need some level
of reliability and clarity
about what you've made.
And I think it's very
easy in data systems
to end up with a mess
that is unexplainable.
MARK MANDEL: Just so people who
aren't as familiar with data
science get an
understanding, what do you
mean by model versioning?
What does that mean?
JULIET HOUGLAND: Let's say you
have a linear regression model.
You can build it once.
You have some data.
You fit it, and it knows
how to predict things.
And you're like, great,
I have my model, right?
In a real production
system, you have this code
that generates modeling.
You have the data
that went into it.
And what you need to
do is apply that code
that knows how to
train a model and get
the parameters to new data.
And so there's maybe two
types of versioning here.
There's a model that
gets trained again,
and you get a new collection
of fit parameters.
But the way that you've
trained it hasn't changed.
And so you probably
want a version that
and understand what data went
in to create these parameters.
And then let's say you want
to add another feature.
This is now different code
and a different structure
of a model and a different
way you've done training.
And even if you apply
it to the same data,
it's a different model.
And so there's two types
of versioning there.
One is that the way
you're producing
the model and the structure of
the model has stayed the same,
but the data is new.
And the other is the structure
of the model has changed,
perhaps also the data.
And those are two types of
versioning that you probably
want to track.
And often it's just sort
of like there are easy ways
to not do model versioning
and to not keep track of that,
which will bite you
later, especially
when you end up trying to get
into [INAUDIBLE] make a model.
Is it any better?
You need to A/B testing.
How do you set up a system
that can do A/B testing?
And how do you know what
went into the two models
that you're comparing?
What the difference is.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We were chatting
offline a little bit
about the tooling, Julia,
that I know your group is using.
Can you explain a little
bit about the type of setup,
especially for the
data-scientist types tools
that you're setting
up with them for them
to be able to do the
work that they're doing?
JULIET HOUGLAND: So we
have cloud infrastructure,
and we allow data
scientists to specify jobs.
Jobs are defined as
Docker containers
running on a cluster.
So this job will be submitted
on a particular cluster.
And these jobs are specified
through an open source
tool we have called Flotilla.
So flotilla is fantastic.
It's super self-service.
Our data scientists
all really like it.
We actually just did a survey
of the data platform tools
and got information from
the data scientists.
And we asked like, what tool
would you miss the most?
40% said Flotilla,
which is great.
And so Flotilla allows data
scientists to use a UI to say,
I want to use this Docker image.
This is the command
I want to run.
Here's some environment
variables that often people
will use to define a git repo
that they want to pull from
and the branch they want to use.
And then we have a
scheduling system
that integrates with that.
And that scheduling
system says, combine,
like make this DAG of jobs and
run it every day at midnight.
Or the first step of those DAG
is wait for data to appear.
And once this data appears, then
run the rest of this workflow.
And so that ends up being
what our self-service ETL
definition and scheduling
system looks like.
And data scientists are pretty
happy with that workflow.
We have tools that are somewhat
custom for building Docker
images because it
came from a world
where we needed to build RPMs,
machine images, and Docker
images, where that
is a little harder
to use for our data scientists.
So we're thinking
of ways that we
can make that simpler, use more
open source tools, hopefully
just give them Docker
files to define.
MELANIE WARRICK: I like it.
Michelle, from your
work in the past, what
have been some of the
pipelines that you've seen,
or what are some ones
that are successful
from your perspective?
MICHELE CASBON: So I was
working for a company called
Cordoba previously.
It's a startup based
here in San Francisco.
And it's essentially a B2B SaaS
platform with machine learning
components.
And so there was sort
of the normal, sort of,
back-end web component of,
like, what you would normally
consider like a typical
web architecture,
typical microservices
architecture.
And then when we
added the machine
learning components to that,
they looked very different.
They didn't have that sort of
standard thousands of companies
have already built an
architecture that looks just
like this.
There are these weird
machine learning components
that we're kind of trying
to tack on to that.
And the way we
solved that problem
is to take things from this
very homogeneous platform
and put it all into a managed
Kubernetes environment, where
we can run everything together
because it's essentially one
application.
It's one cohesive
platform for users.
And by putting that
all in the same place,
we were able to utilize
these very different resource
requirements but have
everything in sort
of a self-contained,
single, manageable space
that you could wrap
your head around
and then also enable the person
writing the machine learning
code to also deploy all
the way through production
and iterate very easily.
But even that still required
specific Docker containers
for each one of those components
for the ingress, for back end,
for search, for the
featurization component,
for data, for all of that.
And that took
awhile to build out,
and it ran very smoothly
once it was in place.
But I took a lot of what I
learned from that experience,
and it really--
I do want to underscore the fact
that it just really transformed
the DevOps experience
at that company.
Like, it took what was a very
onerous sort of just, kind of,
scattered thing-- things were
in lots of different places--
and it just put it into this
one, little neatly packaged
collection, a place you could
really operate on much more
easily and standardize across
all of the different pieces.
But it took a lot of
what I learned there,
and I'm applying that now to
building this Kubeflow project.
And the idea is
the same, where you
have all of these different
pieces of a machine learning
application, and you want
them all in one place
because you want to be
able to version them.
You want to be able
to move them from one
environment to the other
and iterate through
during the development
process and do that in a way
that scales.
And as new hardware comes out--
I think you guys talked recently
about new VMs that came out
with just ridiculous
amounts of RAM and CPU
and being able to not
have to change your code
but still be able
to utilize those
and basically just deploy
it to a new cluster,
a big piece of that was
just using managed services
instead of doing
everything from scratch.
Like originally,
I believe Cordoba
was sort of rolling their own
open source frameworks on VMs
and managing that independently.
And that took a lot
of people hours.
It took a lot of,
sort of, babysitting.
And by switching to managed
Kubernetes, a lot of that
went away.
A lot of the network headaches,
the like hard-coded IP
addresses, a lot of that just
sort of dissolves into some
of the features that you get
from a managed Kubernetes
environment.
So the aim of Kubeflow
is to really take
all of the benefits, everything
that Kubernetes does really
well, and sort of apply that to
a machine learning application.
So that's sort of where I see
the future of machine learning
heading is into this
declarative way of defining
your application.
And you just sort of
define the resources
that you need for each
piece, and then you're
less tied to the physical
hardware that it's running on.
You can just say, hey, I
want GPUs for this piece.
You have all the different
types of hardware
all in the same cluster.
And you don't really
have to think about it.
And Kubernetes and Kubeflow
manages that for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Coming back a little bit
to when we were talking
about the challenge
of reproducibility,
do you have any perspective
on what can make people
feel confident in what is
being used now for models?
Like if it's hard to
reproduce, is it just,
well, we just have to
believe that it's fine
and move forward.
Or--
JULIET HOUGLAND: I find
that most people just
don't question it, right?
There's this blind faith and
like, oh, this is mathematical.
This is analytical.
It must be correct.
It must be true.
And I--
MELANIE WARRICK: You think
they should question more.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS].
JULIET HOUGLAND: Well--
MELANIE WARRICK: They should
consider questioning more.
JULIET HOUGLAND: I think
that business partners that
are coming from less of
an analytical data science
background have
their own questions
and are often too
easily convinced
by this is analytical.
This is mathematical.
It must be true.
I similarly think that data
science practitioners also
get kind of caught up in
that mode of thinking,
that this is analytical.
This is mathematical.
It must be true, right?
And really effective
data scientists
that I've seen tend
to question more
and tend to sort of
work in a simpler mode
so that they can circle
back on that question of,
am I building
something valuable?
Am I making something correct?
Is this something believable?
Because once you get into
the technical nitty-gritty
and build a complex model,
it's easy to convince yourself
that, oh, the ROC is good.
And so I'm not going to
worry about it, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, we did
a podcast machine learning bias
and fairness awhile back, too.
I think that definitely
plays a role here, too.
You don't want to just blindly
follow that this model's fine.
JULIET HOUGLAND: There's not
great automated tools for it,
right?
Like, this is why data
scientists, data science
practitioners with
a lot of experience
that are thoughtful about
what they're building
are really valuable.
They'll take a step back, and
they'll think about have I made
something good?
Have I made something that
this business will find viable
for a long time?
Meaning is it reproducible?
Is it explainable?
MARK MANDEL: So to
that point, if you
had sort of a magic
wand, or either of you
had a magic wand,
where you're like,
this is the tool that I
would love to have right now
and I could just make it with
this magic wand, what would you
make?
MICHELE CASBON: I mean, I would
love something that just spit
out the right model every time.
[LAUGHTER]
It does all of the
developmental work for me.
Like, this is what your
featurization pipeline
should look like.
These are all hyper
parameters you should have.
That would be amazing.
I mean, I think we're
working towards where
we're trying to provide that.
A lot of the managed services,
the point is give us your data,
and we'll try and fit
the best model for you.
I mean, that seems
pretty magical,
and like that day is
not quite here yet.
But I feel like we're
making steps towards that.
JULIET HOUGLAND: I would
say a sort of listener
in a data science environment
that watches what steps a data
scientist takes and sort
of automatically makes
a lab notebook.
Every good scientist
has a lab notebook
where they're making notes about
the environment they're in,
their experiments, their
setup, what happened that day.
I think something
that is automated
that watches and
sort of generates
a lab notebook for a data
scientists would be my dream.
MELANIE WARRICK: I actually
was at a conference
last week on disaster
risk recovery.
And I noticed one of the
key things that was really
a challenge for these
organizations that are trying
to understand and anticipate
and plan and analyze
for potential natural
disasters is just
asking the right question.
Like, what is the
real problem you
can try to solve with technology
to be able to apply it?
It would be great if
you just had something
that could spit out
the model, like I think
what is the real question?
And then what is the
tech and the model
that I should be using
for that question?
JULIET HOUGLAND: So previously
I had worked at Cloudera.
And I did data science there.
And I would occasionally
go out to big customers
and to talk with them about
their data science problems.
So once I went out
to a large customer.
And they have call centers.
And so what they
had done was they
had transcribed calls
to their call centers,
and so they now had
text instead of voice.
And so they brought me in
because they're like, well,
we have this small
five-person analytics team.
And we would like for them
to build an NLP model which
will do entity identification,
entity resolution,
and from these call logs, pick
out pieces of information that
are valuable to us
because they had
resources and customers were
calling for these resources.
And they were only tracking it
if they had the resources they
could give them.
But they wanted to do
understand what the demand was
that they were missing, right?
And so I talked
with them for a bit.
And I realize that
their team does not
have the skills to build
an NLP model like that,
nor is usually building a model
that complex really the answer.
And so I talked to
them for a while,
and I realized that
what they wanted
was to get the structured
information that the call
center representatives
were already
listening to and
putting into a form that
was getting turned into a SQL
query that hit their databases.
And so hearing that, I suggested
that instead of transcribing
their voice to text
and then building
a very complex set of
stacked NLP models,
that perhaps what they
could do is instead
keep the database queries.
And they had spent already a
lot of money and many months
on this project, and they were
a little taken aback but also
pretty excited that they weren't
about to waste a ton more.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's the key part.
JULIET HOUGLAND: Yeah.
MICHELE CASBON: Yeah, I
feel like at the beginning
of every project that is the
number one most crucial thing
you can do is make
sure that you're
asking the right question.
And then if you have the
right question in mind,
can you arrive at the
answer with something
that's very simple and
mathematically straightforward?
Like, if the answer to that is
no, then try machine learning.
But the answer is
not machine learning.
And you certainly
shouldn't start a company
based on I'm going to do
these stacked NLP models
or start a project
with that as the goal.
You really don't want to
let technology or techniques
drive finding answers.
MELANIE WARRICK:
One question I want
to ask both of you, what do you
enjoy most about data science
and data in general,
working with data?
JULIET HOUGLAND: I like that
it's always a challenge.
There's so much to learn.
Using data effectively
is a mixture
of understanding the technology
available to work with data,
understanding the mathematical
techniques available,
and being able to
communicate with people
and understand what the
problem is in general,
and I think that third one
being the most important step.
Because if you just
do the first two,
you end up with things
like transcribing voice
into text and building
stacked NLP models.
But knowing a little bit about
web applications and databases
and then understanding
the problem
is this person is transcribing
it, like that kind of gives you
a good cut off and short cut.
And so I would say
that the part that I
like best about
working with data
is needing to constantly
be improving your skills
on all three fronts.
And maybe that's a
bad way to phrase it.
I tend to focus on improving my
skills on one of those fronts
and then switching between them
over longer periods of time
and not constantly trying to
push myself in every direction.
But always having ways to expand
your skill set technologically
and mathematically, in terms
of humans, I really enjoy that.
And the people are great mostly.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK:
Mostly-- got it.
MICHELE CASBON: Yeah, I feel
like one of my favorite things
is just that there is an
infinite number of directions
to go in.
I feel like data is something
that seems so straightforward.
It's pretty tangible.
It's a thing that should
be well understood
because we've been working
with it for decades.
But every time I
go to solve what
seems like a
straightforward problem,
you just have so many
avenues to go down.
And it's like you can go into--
you can go down so many
different rabbit holes
and solve the problem in
so many different ways,
that it is very challenging
and there's never
a shortage of new things
to learn, of new ways
to tackle the
problem, and that's
also like from a
theoretical perspective,
from a practical perspective.
I never feel like there's
a lack of things to learn
and ways to be challenged.
And the impact that
you can have with that,
going in any
different direction,
just feels like you
can change the world
in so many different
ways, big or small.
That's most exciting to me.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So any resources
that you'd recommend for those
out there interested in data
science, data engineering,
machine learning?
MICHELE CASBON: I really love
the machine learning flashcards
that Chris Albon puts out.
Those are my favorite.
They're just these
little hand-drawn--
like he'll have a formula that
he'll just draw out, literally
like you would do in college.
And I think he started out
just making them for himself.
But there are like 300
now, and he publishes them.
You can purchase them
for like $10, $15.
But they're really, really good.
And just going through a
few of those a day just kind
of refreshes, like keeps
the neurons firing.
I really like those.
It's not a place to start.
But it is a good way to--
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's a good resource.
JULIET HOUGLAND: There's
a lot of different things
that you can develop
and you can learn,
and so one of the
best resources I've
seen that has a sort of
hierarchy and structure
of the different types of
things you could be developing
and learning is a website
called Open Source Data Science
Masters.
MICHELE CASBON: Oh, is
that Claire's website?
That is a really good resource.
JULIET HOUGLAND: Yeah.
And so there's a bunch of
different topics in there.
And I would say one of
the most overlooked skills
for people coming from
a software background
to data science
is linear algebra.
And so when linear
algebra's the best.
[LAUGHTER]
Start there.
It'll help you so much.
MICHELE CASBON: Yeah, it's
a really good foundational.
Like the stronger your linear
algebra foundations are,
the easier machine learning is.
JULIET HOUGLAND: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
This has been great.
I know we're pretty much
out of time at this point.
But was there
anything else that you
wanted to mention
before we wrap up,
any places that
you'll be speaking?
JULIET HOUGLAND: Stitch
Fix is always hiring.
Come work with us.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
MICHELE CASBON: I hear
it's a great place to work.
MELANIE WARRICK: So do I.
MICHELE CASBON: From many
other people, not just Juliet.
But it is one of the
places that has had--
really from the beginning,
it was a data science-driven
organization.
And it's one of the
most respected places
to work as a data scientist.
And I hear it's
awesome to work for,
so many wonderful
women, just like Juliet.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, definitely.
JULIET HOUGLAND: Awesome.
Thank you, Michelle.
That's great.
Come work at Stitch Fix.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: Michelle's
not getting paid this.
MARK MANDEL:
Michelle, did you want
to add anything at your end?
MICHELE CASBON: I
think our team is also
hiring if you want to work in
developer relations at Google.
MELANIE WARRICK:
But are you going
to be speaking
anywhere anytime soon?
MICHELE CASBON: I
will be at Docker Con
here in SF in a few weeks.
That is June 12th, the 13th,
somewhere around there.
I'll be doing a community
session with Jay Smith.
We'll be talking about Kubeflow.
And it's kind of an
"unconference" style.
It's like a three-hour
session, where we tell you
a little bit about Kubeflow.
There are a couple of other open
source projects there as well.
And then we talk
about what we want
to work on next and kind
of some of the hot button
issues in the community.
Please join the
community if you're
interested in hearing
more about Kubeflow.
If you just google Kubeflow,
you'll find there's--
we're a GitHub Kubeflow
repo, kubeflow/kubeflow.
There's also a mailing list.
I believe that's all on there.
But if you go to
github.com/kubeflow/community,
any of those links, those
will lead you to our project.
MARK MANDEL: We'll put
them in the show notes.
Well, thank you to both of
you for coming on the podcast
today.
It's been really great and a
super interesting interview.
MICHELE CASBON:
Thanks for having us.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, thank you.
JULIET HOUGLAND: Yeah, thanks.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks again
to Juliet and Michelle
for joining us today
on the podcast--
super interesting
conversation talking
about data science pipelines
and how all that stuff gets
built out.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
All right, Mark, so
question of the week--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: If I've
written a gRPC service
but I'm using a language or
platform that isn't supported,
is there any way I can
access it as a rest?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah so
I really like gRPC.
So if you're not
familiar with gRPC,
it stands for gRPC
Remote Procedure Call.
So it's recursive.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Always, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: It's a great way of
building remote procedure call
systems.
It does a lot of
really cool stuff.
One of the things
that's great about gRPC
is it sends things like
protobuf over the wire.
It uses HTTP2.
So it has some
requirements, and there's
a set of languages
that are supported.
So if you're using a
language or a platform that
isn't supported, like say maybe
JavaScript on the browser,
or maybe there's a particular
language it hasn't been built
for yet, something like
that, you can actually
expose it as rest.
And there's a couple
of tools that'll
let you do that, each it's,
kind of, pros and cons.
The one that came out first--
yeah, I'm going to say it came
out first-- is an open source
product that was in the gRPC
ecosystem repository called
gRPC Gateway.
It's literally a
tool and/or a library
that you can either
do it one of two ways.
If you've got a gRPC
service written as Go,
you can basically
use it as a library
to expose your
endpoints as HTTP.
You just put some
extra configuration
in your protofile.
And you can do it that way.
It'll also generate Swagger,
do some other nice stuff too.
But it can also
be used as a proxy
if you want to do
it that way too.
So if you have a gRPC service
in a different language
or you just want to
put a proxy in front
without having to work in the
same process, you can do that.
And that works really nicely.
The other thing that
is also possible
is you can use another
proxy called Envoy.
Envoy's got a lot of
popularity recently,
came out of collaborations
between Lyft and Google
and probably a whole bunch
of other people as well.
It does a whole bunch of stuff.
But one of the things
that could also do is also
do gRPC conversions
to HTTP and JSON,
so essentially rest very
much, in exactly the same vein
as gRPC Gateway does actually
as well, which is kind of neat.
It uses the same configuration.
And finally, should also
make mention of the fact
that if you're running
on Google Cloud,
we have a product called Cloud
Endpoints will actually do
exactly the same thing as well.
So you can also use that to
convert from gRPC to HTTP
endpoints.
And the neat thing
is all three of them
use exactly the
same configuration.
So you can actually try one.
I would say pretty much
switch between the others,
really, relatively easily.
We'll add some more
documentation to the show noes
as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Well, thanks for that, Mark.
So Mark, where are
you going to be?
MARK MANDEL: What am I doing?
What's going on?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Last week you did your talk.
Actually, how did it go?
MARK MANDEL: That was fun.
We had a good time,
had a good chat
about how you can't
just add more servers.
But on the 14th of
June, I will actually
be presenting on Agones,
speaking of which,
at the San Francisco
Kubernetes meet-up.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So I'll be
there chatting about that.
What are you getting up to?
MELANIE WARRICK: I
am slated to speak
on June 26th at a joint
event by PyLadies and Women
in Machine Learning
and Data Science.
We're going to be talking
about paths to data science.
Once I have more
details on that,
I'll add that in the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Fantastic.
Well, Melanie, thank you
for once again joining me
on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELANIE WARRICK: (SINGING
"ADAM'S FAMILY" THEME SONG)
Duh-nuh-nuh, nut.
MARK MANDEL: Eh, uh.
MELANIE WARRICK: Duh-nuh-nuh,
nut, duh-nuh-nuh, nut.
Duh-nuh-nuh, nut.
[SNAP] [SNAP]
[LAUGHTER]